okay so my talk at the table is
ventriloquist and comedian Jeff Dunham
his 11th yeah that's right 11th comedy
special Jeff Dunham need the people
premieres Friday on Comedy Central which
is part of Paramount Global like CBS
News in the one hour special Dunham is
joined by his iconic characters like
Walter Bubba J peanut and his newest
dummy Earl in this clip one of his most
popular characters Bubba J shares new
lessons he's learned take a look
I think that installing a smoke detector
in my chimney was a bad idea
sometimes I get so drunk that I care and
under how to set my alarm clock so I
just turn on my microwave for eight
hours
from now on no more prostate exams
unless it's by someone who actually
works in the medical field
first on CBS mornings Jeff Dunham joins
us right now good morning good morning
thanks for having us
not it's good to see you guys I must say
I heard the emotion Michelle hold on a
thing about looking in the mirror and
saying hey buddy in the morning Jeff
does it every day every day
all right so Jeff let's start with you
all right um you say the most important
ingredients for comedy are tension and
conflict right why so uh well that's
just you know that's what I love about
what I do is that rather than just a
manologist being on stage telling jokes
and you know making them giving opinions
uh peanut and I are the other characters
and I can just talk about whatever we
want to talk about and I can give one
side of the issue and they can give the
other side of the issue so we can talk
about a lot of things that other guys
can't talk about on stage yeah whatever
sometimes seems a little confused by
what you're saying right who does peanut
seems sometimes oh I am never concerned
are you kidding me no I'm fine it's all
good it's all great I mean so go ahead
well the current tour I mean on the
subject of tension and conflict yeah the
current tour is uh still not canceled
right and you say you don't care about
getting canceled is that just because
you got a big pile of money or no it is
uh you know it's a difficult time to be
a comedian right now because there's so
many things you can't joke about you'll
get canceled immediately for saying
whatever but I'm I'm one of the guys
trying to bring comedy back because uh
uh I look back to the guys like Will
Rogers Bob Hope Carson Leno and you
never knew what those guys were where
what their side was politically and uh
they would make fun of anybody and
everybody both sides whoever was in
office and it was okay and I think our
country had a better sense of humor then
but I think what's happened is a lot of
comedians have now uh they pick a side
and then they start name calling and
pointing fingers and call the other side
you know idiots and so
um what that does is you eliminate have
the audience right so I think there's an
easier way not an easier way I think
there's a better way of just making a
little fun of everybody because I think
we all I think most people in this
country have a decent sense of humor
yeah you can be made fun of a little bit
but don't point fingers and call names
and uh you know look when Trump was in
office I had a lot of fun with that and
yeah Biden's in office you saw one of
the clips Walter one of my characters is
is you know everybody has said for years
since Obama mama was in office that he
looks like Biden so I I'm just kind of
embracing that now and on stage the
fourth wall is gone he knows he's
dressed up like button but he's become
Biden and but we're not being mean about
it you know what I mean people from the
left come to my show people from the
right come to my show and uh I everybody
has an equally good time and I just I'm
trying to make it that again yeah can
you say sometimes listen you have an
audience of 102 people may be offended
right do we now have to react to the to
two people being offended because most
people you say get the joke well look
we've all learned a lot in the last few
years we really have there's certain
topics that you don't joke about certain
things that you don't say Obviously but
I think if somebody if a comedian has
done his or her craft and had done it a
long time you know that line you know
how far you can push things and I think
a comedian's job is to push it just a
little bit further yeah and that's what
gets the big laugh like I say how you
work there Jeff with all of his
characters yeah no doubt Jeff I'm tired
of listening to you uh peanuts so what
is it like working with Jeff uh
everything is fine how long have we been
together we have been together since
1986. 86 peanuts yeah that's right yeah
so uh hold on a second so Tony Tony was
saying earlier before the segment
started that you were in high school
watching us that's depressing yeah well
I made as well me too
I have to admit
yeah
screwed up a lot of kids
no but I like all the different
characters that you work with peanut the
new one Earl it's spelled by URL yeah
what can you tell us about earlier well
it was you know when the pandemic well
when the pandemic started I had never I
started this in the third grade my first
show was a book report in the third
grade yeah and I've never done anything
else this was it so I started getting
paid in the fourth grade doing Cub Scout
Banquets and shows at church growing up
in Dallas and then it just kept growing
and by the time the pandemic hit I
realized that I had never gone in my
entire life more than two two weeks
without doing a show what so oh yeah
always a performance always always
always wow and so even in my honeymoon
uh Audrey and I got married 10 years ago
I took a month off and that was it but
other than that the pandemic hit and I'm
sitting at home doing I want to do and
uh so I decided to show the people How I
build the dummies How I build the
characters and I started a series of
YouTube lives and Facebook lives
building this new character who's a guy
that stuck on his smart device a little
too much of the time I always try and
create characters that we can all
identify with and so when I finished and
we had a naming contest from the fans
and one guy came up with the brilliant
name of Earl but spell it URL and he's
been going over great because who who
doesn't know that guy we are that guy
right no doubt about it we are that I
was following that story I thought you
were about to say you brought a dummy on
your honeymoon well I was glad I'm glad
he's specified
voices Jeff Dunham thank you so much
Jeff Dunham feed the people he's still
married on Comedy Central